i've watched the show and i think you
guys are all amazing and it
feels really safe yeah but it also feels
honest and it feels like we're gonna all
lay it out here and it's gonna be like
an open conversation
olivia jade is breaking her silence and
opening up for the first time
publicly about the college admissions
scandal that landed both of her parents
in prison
on monday the 21 year old daughter of
lori lachlan and massimo gianouli
announced on instagram that she will
appear on tuesday's episode of jada
pinkett smith's red table talk on
facebook watch
teasing in the caption that she will
quote publicly share my experience for
the first time
and now a source tells e.t she has her
parents
full support the family and their team
all agreed
now was the time for olivia to speak out
and they're all
supportive of her olivia has been
wanting to get back in the limelight and
share her side of things for some time
now
and is looking forward to getting back
out there i'm literally moving into
college
today i do want the experience of like
game days
partying i don't really care about
school
as you guys all know et source adds that
olivia misses her
youtube career and quote knows there
will be some hurdles ahead of her
but she is ready to face things head-on
and ultimately get back into the swing
of things
olivia's parents are currently serving
their prison sentences after pleading
guilty in may to one count of conspiracy
to commit wire and mail fraud
and honest services wire and mail fraud
i just want them to have that experience
and get that education
and have a degree to fall back on
massimo and lori paid 500 000 in bribes
to get both
olivia and her older sister 22 year old
bella
admitted to the university of southern
california as recruits for the crew team
even though neither of them had ever
participated in the sport
i want them to be happy so i want to be
supportive of everything they want to do
but i do want them to have
somewhat of a normal you know finish out
high school college experience maybe
because i didn't have that i really want
that for them
they initially pleaded not guilty to all
charges leveled against them
claiming their payments were donations
to the school and
not bribes last month the source told et
that the fuller
house star is in constant communication
with her daughters while serving her
two-month prison sentence at the federal
correctional institution
in dublin california lori's been
communicating daily with her family and
is trying her best to get acclimated to
her new surroundings
but she's ready to go home never in a
million years did lori ever think she'd
be behind bars in her lifetime
and she had a very difficult time
dealing with that reality
as for olivia and bella our source says
they are keeping it together for their
mom
her girls are worried about her and are
doing everything they can to reassure
her that she can do this
and trying to help her stay strong
[Music]
you